Hủ hại quan vừa bán hành công văn hoa tốt thùng báo đến các cơ quan liên quan.
Cơ đơn vị trực thuộc thông tin tại khoản thu, mừng sách nhả nước,
đảm bảo sự khai hoa đậu chính quyền địa phương hai cấp từ ngày 1 mồ tháng bẩy.
Cục hại quan thùng báo, mắc cơ quan hại quan, tài khoản chuyên thu,
tài khoản tảm thu, tài khoản tảm dữ,
khó bạc nhả nước nơi cơ quan hại quan,
2 bế chi cuộc hại quan khu vực bởi đến vị trực thu, hại quan khu vực mồ tài khoản.
Để bộ máy hoa đậu theo mồ hình chính quyền địa phương hai cấp,
bất hành từ ngày 1 mồ tháng bẩy.
Lên quan đến đảm bảo hoa đậu thông xuất chính quyền địa phương hai cấp,
để tạo điều kiện cho cán mộ, công trước tác nghiệp.
Tránh việc dịch dịch nhìn yếu tươi ở đến nơi công tác,
cuộc hại quan cũng tính đến việc ổn định nơi làm việc,
chỗ sinh hoa.
Theo đó, sẽ nghiên cứu chiến hại xe dựng nhà công vụ để đảm bảo chỗ sinh hoa của cán mộ,
công trước hại quan khi sắp xếp lại địa dựa hại chính,
cuộc cũng sẽ tức tục ra sốt lại các văn bản quy phám pháp lật,
quy định để đáp ở yêu cầu thức tế,
không anh vừa đến công tác nghiệp vụ phương hợp với bộ máy mới của chính quyền địa phương hai cấp.